PROFESSOR: All
right, spin orbit.
We have it still there,
delta H spin orbit, orbit.
Well, we know what V is.
So that derivative, dv dr can
be taken care of, the 1 over r.
That gives you e squared over 2m
c squared 1 over r cubed S, L.
And you remember that S, L,
from 805, J squared minus S
squared minus L squared.
The reason that's why you
tend to do addition of angular
momentum, because S and
L, calculating the matrix
elements of this
thing is very easy,
in that base is because
every state there
has a fixed value of S squared,
a fixed value of L squared.
And j squared plus a
couple of possibilities.
So we must work with
the couple basis.
Basis.
And therefore, we can attempt to
find E1 of a N, L, J, MJ, spin
orbit, equal e squared over 2m
squared c squared and LJ, MJ,
S, L, R cubed.
The R cube has to stay
inside the expectation value,
because the expectation
value includes
integration over space.
So this is a very important.
N, L, J, MJ.
And again the useful
question, the couple basis
will have have degeneracies.
All the states are
degenerate there.
So this time, we fixed n,
because the degeneracies
happen only when you fix n.
So do we have the
right to do this,
to use the formula
form perturbation,
the non-degenerate perturbation
theory to do this calculation?
And the answer is yes, because
the perturbation S.L over R
cubed commutes with with
L squared, with J squared,
and with Jz.
you need all that because
you can have degeneracies
by having different L values.
And that would be taken
care by this operator that
has different eigenvalues
when L is different.
You can have the degeneracies
involving different J values.
This would be taken
by this operator.
And you can have
degeneracies when
m has different value so that
involves the Jz operator.
So you really need
a perturbation
that commutes with all of them.
And why does it commute
with all of them?
You can see it in several ways.
Let's do L squared.
L squared is Casimir,
it commutes with any LI.
It doesn't even think
about S because it doesn't
know anything about S.
So it commutes with S.
So L squared with any
LI and commutes with S.
And L squared is
an invariant, it
commute with r squared
because r squared
is rotational invariant.
So everything commute with that.
In order to do the
other ones, you
can also think in terms of
this matrix J squared over here
and S squared and
do all of them.
You should do it and convince
yourself that they all commute.
So we can do this.
If we can do it, it's
good because then we
can evaluate these quantities.
So let's do a little
of the the evaluation.
So this E1nljmj is equal to.
Let's evaluate the S dot L
part by using 1/2 j squared
s squared minus L squared.
So that gives you a factor
of h bar squared over 2,
with this 2 over there.
So you get e squared
h squared over 4m
squared c squared, J times
J plus 1 minus l times l
plus 1 minus 3/4, times
nljmj, 1 over r cubed, mljmj.
OK.
That should be
clear from the fact
that you have a j
squared minus s squared.
That's a 3/4 spin is
always 1/2, and l squared.
This is known.
It's equal, in fact, to
nlml 1 over cubed nlml.
Which is equal, let
me discuss that again.
It's a little-- a0l,
l plus 1, l plus 1/2.
OK.
So this is a known result. It's
one of those expectation values
that you can get from
Feynman, Hellman,
or for other
recursion relations.
And this is always computed in
the original uncoupled basis.
But we seem to need it
in the coupled basis.
So again, are we in trouble?
No.
This is actually the same.
And it is the same only
because this answer
doesn't depend on ml.
Because this states involve
various combinations of ml
and ms. But doesn't
depend on ml,
so the answer is
really the same.
So these things are
Happily, that
simplifies our work.
And now we have E1
nljm is equal to En 0--
this is yet another notation,
this is the ground state energy
here--
mc squared n, j, j plus 1
minus l, l plus 1 minus 3/4,
over l, l plus 1/2, l plus 1.
OK this is spin orbit.